♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT JOINING
US NOW WAS WE CONTINUE OUR
SPECIAL INVESTIGATION AND
RACKING TO TODAY'S BREAKING
NEWS OHIO CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN, FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN
RON DESANTIS AND JUDICIAL
WATCH PRESIDENT TOM FITTON.
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN, LET
ME START WITH YOU.
>> SURE.
>> Sean: THIS IS AN AMAZING
THING THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN,
WHO APPOINTED ROBERT
MUELLER, WHO IS THE SAME GUY
THAT EXTENDED THE FISA
WARRANT WITH THE PHONEY
DOSSIER, WHICH WAS THE BULK
OF INFORMATION, THAT HE
IS -- HE DID NOT WANT DEVIN
NUNES TO GET ANY OF THIS
MATERIAL AND THAT ONLY
BECAUSE OF DIGGING BY YOU
AND CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS AND
YOUR STAFFS WERE WE ABLE TO
FIND THE LATEST STRZOK-PAGE
MESSAGES WHICH SHOW ALL OF
THIS, YOU KNOW, COLLUSION,
IF YOU WILL, TO USE A TERM
OR AT LEAST RELATIONSHIP
WITH THIS JUDGE THAT RECUSED
HIMSELF AFTER HE ACCEPTED
GENERAL FLYNN'S PLEA.
>> RIGHT.
EXACTLY RIGHT, SEAN.
THREE KEY POINTS.
>> Sean: HELP ME OUT HERE.
>> YOU SAID IT WELL.
THE JUDGE RECUSES HIMSELF IN
THE FLYNN CASE.
THAT SAME JUDGE, THE TEXT
MESSAGES MAKE VERY CLEAR HAD
A FRIENDSHIP AND
RELATIONSHIP WITH PETER
STRZOK, THE GUY WHO WAS
DEPUTY HEAD OF COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE AT THE FBI AND
THE -- EXCUSE ME, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO GET THAT
INFORMATION.
IN FACT, THE COPIES THAT WE
GOT, THE DOCUMENTS THAT WE
GOT WERE REDACTED.
WE HAD TO SEND STAFF,
MR. MEADOW'S STAFF WENT IN
THERE AND FOUND THE
INFORMATION WHICH SHOWS THE
RELATIONSHIP SO, HE RECUSED
HIMSELF AS YOU SAID AFTER
THE CASE, NOT BEFORE.
HE HAD A RELATIONSHIP THAT
JUDGE HAD A RELATIONSHIP
WITH PETER STRZOK AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
DIDN'T WANT US TO FIND IT
OUT.
THE KEY QUESTION IS WHY?
>> Sean: LET'S GO THROUGH
THAT KEY QUESTION.
RON DESANTIS THAT IS A KEY
QUESTION.
WHY?
A JUDGE DOESN'T TAKE ON A
CASE, THEN RECUSE HIMSELF
AND THEN WE FIND THE JUDGE
IS BEST FRIENDS AT THE HEART
OF EVERYTHING PETER STRZOK.
>> YEAH, SEAN.
JUST REMEMBER, THIS WAS SUCH
AN ODD CASE FROM THE
BEGINNING WITH FLYNN.
THEY RUSHED IN TO
INTERROGATE HIM IN THE WHITE
HOUSE JANUARY OF 2017.
OBVIOUSLY, HE ENDS UP
PLEADING GUILTY BUT HE
PROBABLY DIDN'T KNOW ALL
THAT WAS GOING ON WITH PETER
STRZOK.
AND SO THIS THING JUST IS
NOT -- DOES NOT SIT WELL
WITH ME.
AND I ALSO HAVE AN ISSUE AS
JIMMY SAID WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THEY FOUGHT US TOOTH AND
NAIL ON EVERYTHING PRETTY
MUCH.
INCLUDING THIS RIGHT HERE.
WHY WERE THEY HEAVILY
REDACTING THIS PORTION.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE
WERE ENTITLED TO SEE.
IN CONDUCTING OVERSIGHT.
THEY TRIED TO HIDE IT FROM
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: YEAH.
TOM FITTON YOU HAVE
STRUGGLED AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION HAS STRUGGLED.
WHY ARE THEY TRYING TO HIDE,
REMEMBER, DEVIN NUNES WAITED
UNTIL THE FINAL FIVE MINUTES
BEFORE THE SUBPOENA OF THIS
INFORMATION FROM THE DOJ
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN HANDED
OVER MUCH EARLIER AND NOW
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN,
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS,
CONGRESSMAN DESANTIS, THEY
HAVE TO SEND THEIR ENTIRE
STAFFS OVER.
THEY CAN'T EVEN TAKE A
PICTURE OF ANYTHING.
IT'S LIKE DON'T THEY HAVE
OVERSIGHT, ISN'T THAT PART
OF CHECKS AND BALANCES
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES ARE TO
CHECK AND BALANCE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THINGS DON'T GO
WRONG.
>> OVERSIGHT NOT ONLY FROM
CONGRESS AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND FBI DO.
BUT ALSO FROM THE COURTS.
WE'RE IN FEDERAL COURT
ASKING FOR THESE TYPES OF
TEXT MESSAGES.
AND WE'RE GETTING THE
PROVERBIAL HAND TO THE FACE.
THERE IS THIS CULTURE OF
ARROGANCE AT THE FBI AND
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THAT IMPEDES VIRTUALLY ANY
OVERSIGHT EITHER BY JUDICIAL
WATCH TO THE COURTS OR
CONGRESS THROUGH ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL POWERS.
AND IT'S REAL CONCERNING
THAT THIS ISN'T HAPPENING
DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION BUT BY
APPOINTEES PRESIDENT TRUMP
JEFF SESSIONS HAS GOT TO
STEP UP AND TAKE BACK
CONTROL OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
ROD ROSENSTEIN HAS A
PERSONAL INTEREST, IT SEEMS
TO ME, IN KEEPING THIS
INFORMATION AWAY AND
DIRECTOR WRAY IS COMPLETELY
OUT TO LUNCH ON THESE ISSUES
WHERE IS HE MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE INSTITUTION OF THE
FBI AND PROTECTING ITS
REPUTATION THAN CLEANING
HOUSE IN TERMS OF THE
CORRUPTION ISSUES.
YOU KNOW, AND NOW WE HAVE
GOT THIS ISSUE NOW ABOUT THE
COURT.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN -- I
KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
JUDICIAL ETHICS PROCESS.
CAN I TELL YOU IT'S UNUSUAL
FOR A COURT TO RECUSE
THEMSELVES FROM A CASE LIKE
THIS WITHOUT AN EXPLANATION.
IT'S UNUSUAL AND THESE
TELLING YOU IN PUBLIC WHAT
WAS THE REASON FOR DOING SO
IN SUCH A HIGH PROFILE CASE.
>> SEAN, IT'S UNUSUAL FOR
THE JUDGE TO RECUSE HIMSELF
AT ANY TIME.
IT'S REALLY UNUSUAL FOR HIM
TO RECUSE HIMSELF AFTER THAT THE
CASE HAS BEEN DECIDED.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
JUDGE CONTRERAS RELATIONSHIP
WITH PETER STRZOK IN ALL OF
THIS.
>> AND ALSO PETER STRZOK'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH MICHAEL
FLYNN.
HE WAS THERE AT THE
INTERVIEW OF MICHAEL FLYNN
WHEN MICHAEL FLYNN SAID
SOMETHING FALSE TO THE FBI.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ALL THIS
FITS TOGETHER.
THESE THREE KEY FACTS
HAPPENED.
THERE WAS WAS A RECUSAL
THERE WAS A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE JUDGE AND PETER
STRZOK.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WAS MAKING IT VERY
DIFFICULT AS CONGRESS BOTH
TOM AND RON HAVE POINTED OUT
TO DO OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OVERSIGHT.
THOSE THREE FACTS ARE
INDISPUTABLE.
SO, LET'S ASK WHY THAT WAS
THE CASE.
WHY CAN'T WE GET THE
INFORMATION AND WHY IN FACT
DID THIS JUDGE RECUSE
HIMSELF?
>> Sean: LET'S GO BACK TO
THIS NEW REVEAL AND IT SAYS
CONGRESSMAN DESANTIS IN A
TEXT MESSAGE WITH STRZOK,
PAGE TO STRZOK, RUDY MEANS
JUDGE CONTRERAS IS ON THE
FISA COURT.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
JUST APPOINT YOU HAD TWO
MONTHS AGO AND THEY DISCUSS
OTHER THINGS AND OF COURSE
PETER STRZOK SAYS WE DID.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE
AND AFTER.
I NEED TO GET TOGETHER WITH
HIM.
THESE TWO HATE DONALD TRUMP.
AND THEN THEY ARE BEST
FRIENDS WITH THE JUDGE ON
THE FISA COURT.
NOW, THERE WERE FOUR
SEPARATE FISA COURT JUDGES
THAT WERE ALL LIED TO
BECAUSE THEY NEVER INFORMED
THE JUDGES IN THE
APPLICATION THAT HILLARY HAD
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
UNVERIFIED, UNCORROBORATED
WHAT TURNED OUT TO BE MANY
RUSSIAN LIES TO INFLUENCE
THE ELECTION.
CONGRESSMAN?
>> WELL, I WILL TELL YOU,
YOU KNOW, PETER STRZOK HAS
DONE SO MUCH DANG TO THE
REPUTATION OF THE FBI WITH
HIS ARROGANCE.
I MEAN, HIM AND LISA PAGE
ARE SITTING THERE SAYING
WELL, LET'S MANUFACTURE A
SOCIAL SETTING OR DARREN
PARTY SO I CAN TALK
PARTY SO - CAN TALK
PARTY SO --CAN TALK
PARTY SO -- AN TALK
PARTY SO -- A DTALK
PARTY SO -- A DINLK
PARTY SO -- A DINNER PARTY
SO I CAN TALK WITH HIM.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
WE NEED TO GET ALL THE
DOCUMENTS ABOUT ALL THE FISA
APPLICATION.
I KNOW CONTRERAS WAS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE JUDGES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL
NOT GIVE US THE TRANSCRIPTS.
THEY WON'T GIVE US THE
DOCUMENTS.
AND, YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF WHY WOULD THEY NOT
WANT TO DO THIS, IF THIS WAS
ALL ON THE UP AND UP.
WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO CLEAR
THE AIR SO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FIGHT ON THEY FIGHT
US TOOTH AND NAIL ON EVERY
ISSUE.
>> Sean: WHAT ELSE ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR TOM FITTON.
>> WE WANT THE FISA
APPLICATIONS.
WE UNDERSTAND THE FISA COURT
WAS MISLEAD.
THESE TWO NEW TEXT MESSAGES
RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THE FISA COURT
PROCESS WAS CORRUPTED
INTERNALLY.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANY JUDGE
DID ANYTHING WRONG,
CERTAINLY ENOUGH FOR THE
COURT TO BEGIN AN INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION OF HOW THE
JUDGES COMMUNICATED WITH THE
FBI, WERE ALL THE
COMMUNICATIONS APPROPRIATE
AND DISCLOSED IN A WAY THAT
THE PUBLIC CAN BE ASSURED
THAT THERE WAS THE FAIR
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE IN
THE OPERATIONS OF THE FISA
COURT.
I TELL YOU, THIS CORRUPTION
AT THE OBAMA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND FBI WHICH
CONTINUES TODAY NOT ONLY
RUINED THE JUSTIN DEPARTMENT
AND FBI IT'S SPLASHED ONTO
THE COURT.
WHAT A DISASTER.
YOU HAVE GOT IT SEND YOUR
STAFF OVER EVERY DAY.
HE IS THAT THE ONLY WAY WE
CAN GET THE INFORMATION THAT
HAS TO HAPPEN EVERY DAY.
>> I WANT TO BE REAL CLEAR.
WE DO NOT KNOW IF THIS JUDGE
IN ANY WAY SIGNED OFF ON
THESE FISA WARRANTS.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT THIS
SERIES OF FACTS RAISES
CONCERNS AND RAISES THE
OBVIOUS QUESTION WHY IT
HAPPENED.
>> Sean: TRUMP HATERS IN THE
COUNTRY HAS SO MUCH POWER
BRAGGING ABOUT HIS
RELATIONSHIP AND, IN FACT,
THE JUDGE KNOWS ALL ABOUT
WHAT HE DOES.